[Music]
residents at a northeast valley mobile
home park are just scrambling to find a
new home after they say they had very
little time less than a month to move on
tuesday those living at the desert
paradise mobile home park on las vegas
boulevard and nellis have to vacate the
property jeremy j ford spoke to
residents who are trying to figure out
what's next
about 32 families are being forced to
evacuate this property after receiving a
notice for unhabitable conditions nobody
in the county is stepping up to take
care of what they need to take care of
for any of these residents frustrations
for desert paradise resident maggie
lunsford brown she tells me she's aware
that residents must leave but claims she
and other residents are not in a
position to i'm terminally ill if i am
under any kind of stress cancer feeds
off stress this will kill me i've been
looking for places
and there's nothing out there victoria
de leon says right now she pays 600
dollars in rent and moving prices in
today's market are just unreasonable
with the credit score and they wanted
you to make three times the amount of
rent
it's just not looking very promising but
for now de leon says she just wants to
see everyone get the relocation help
they need i have kids so i can't really
risk you know staying and being like oh
yeah we won't go you know but
i just would like them to to take care
of the people that live here jeremy j
ford live local now